hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the most famous and captivating
ideas that Plato brought forth into the
world of thought passed on to us all the
way down to the present is his allegory
of the cave and this is found in the
beginning of book 7 of one of his
longest works the Republic this is an
allegory and as I'm pointing out here an
allegory is a kind of story that doesn't
have all of its meaning on the surface
it should be a fairly interesting story
and this one is in order to captivate
the audience's attention but it gestures
or refers beyond itself often with an
explanation as Plato indeed provides
here to a bigger more important more
fundamental story and in this case Plato
has these imaginary prisoners who if you
you know question the story closely they
couldn't really exist in the way that
he's depicting them as we'll talk about
in just a moment but it's supposed to be
a story about not only everybody in his
own time but all of us human beings in
the present in the future in the past
the general human condition and what
education not just what passes for
education but what genuine education the
way that Plato conceives Evette would in
effect be doing so what he's providing
us here is a sort of blueprint for what
real education would look like and he's
going to frame it in terms of his famous
doctrine of the forms and he's going to
introduce an idea that only comes up at
a few other places you might call it the
form beyond forms the super form the
form of the good here in the Republic
also called the form of the beautiful in
the symposium so we have this allegory
and I will go through it because there
may be a few people who have not yet
already been introduced
to it I'm not depicting it in any sort
of graphic form because there's plenty
of resources out there cartoons and
images where you can find people
providing depictions of this in a way
that self referential II would perhaps
trap us back in another cave so we want
to do this in inwards and we can talk
about this original condition of these
prisoners Plato tells us imagine some
prisoners who are not people that
suddenly became prisoners they have been
they have been in a prison underground
their entire life since birth they don't
know anything other than that prison and
their heads are kept facing forward at
all times now they can talk with each
other but they cannot turn their heads
around and this is particularly
important because behind them in this
cave are some other human beings and
these other human beings are walking
across something like a bridge or an
elevated area and there's a fire behind
them projecting light onto the wall of
the cave that's in front of them and
these figures walk back and forth and
converse and also hold up objects or
marionettes or stick figures of things
that then cast shadows on the wall in
front of these prisoners and you have to
imagine these prisoners as being
occupied the entire day long with just
looking ahead and hearing some things
that are reflecting off of the cave wall
so they sound as if because of the echo
that they are coming directly from the
cave wall and they are watching these
shows of a certain sort and they
converse with each other they compete
about who can name or predict what's
going on the best and they give prizes
and here the analogy starts to get a
little bit stretched how do they
actually give these prizes we don't know
Plato doesn't tell us you know and you
can add all sorts of other questions in
there what do they eat how do they
the bathroom where do they sleep you
know that's immaterial to the story
itself obviously you couldn't
effectively do this in the way that
Plato is describing but he's after some
sort of point
now putting aside the people who are in
the background and are in some degree in
the know they understand what the
situation is and ignoring them for the
for the time being because Plato doesn't
really tell us much about them or why
they're doing this what is the condition
of these people who are trapped as
prisoners they are kept in a condition
of ignorance of Perpetual ignorant but
it's not merely ignorance they in fact
think that they know what's going on
they have formed some sort of
conclusions about what reality is and
they think that reality are these
shadows of objects cast on the wall and
the voices that they're hearing you
could say that for them reality is the
complex or the totality of what is going
on in front of their eyes and ears now
they're not perceiving these as shadows
as such because they don't know that
there are objects casting them they
don't know that this is light produced
by a fire that is projected onto their
field of vision so they don't even know
what they don't know and they think that
they understand reality so we have these
poor people stuck in this condition and
then one day one of them is brought out
of the cave probably kicking and
screaming Plato doesn't tell us that but
we can well imagine he says it will be
painful and if you've ever gone from a
condition of low light out into the
sunlight or make it even starker
right you're brought from a condition of
low light say in the winter
out into a winter scape with the Sun
blazing and like coming at you from all
around that's very painful for your eyes
and that's you who's actually lived a
life mostly in the light now imagine
you've been in this cave your entire
existence so he's brought out and at
first this prisoner is having a very
rough time Plato talks about and he says
this explicitly a process of
rehabilitate once instead the the
prisoner now freed so let's call him the
liberated person has to be nursed and
guided through making some sense out of
this new environment and there are some
reference points that are connected to
the things that he has some experience
with first he looks at shadows and he
was able to understand these he can
relate to shadows but now he actually
has the potential to understand them as
shadows there's shadows of things
perhaps a tree perhaps his own shadow
and now he also starts to see
reflections of things as Plato says
likenesses or similitudes or reflections
in water of these things finally he's
able to lift his eyes and turn his
attention to the myriad things around
him trees animals people artifacts all
of the things that we could call the
architecture and furniture of our waking
world and he's able to slowly fix his
eyes upon them later after adjusting in
that way he is able to look a little bit
further up and to regard as Plato says
the heavens and the things of the
heavens to look at the stars to look at
the moon to look at the clouds to look
at
ooh sky and there's one thing that's
particularly central in the heavens that
assumes a very important role here and
that's the Sun and if you've ever looked
at the Sun directly and try to hold your
gaze upon it you know how difficult that
is for those of us who already live in
the waking world above the cave it takes
some doing to stare at the Sun and you
shouldn't do it for too long by the way
right there are some people have managed
to burn their eyes out by doing this
continuously but by looking at the Sun
you can start to see things once your
eyes adjust to it and this person is
able to form not just a visual image of
the Sun but a conception of the Sun the
Sun as generative of all the things that
are all the things that exist it is the
cause he says in a certain way and it
provides them with a sort of order Plato
talks here about the ordering of the
seasons for example but we could think
about all the other things that go with
it and so far this sounds really great
the prisoner has come out into the wide
world above he's no longer deluded
living in a tawdry little puppet show
which isn't even a really a puppet show
it's just a shadow show of silhouettes
and he sees the real things for what
they are and how they're ordered this is
a revelation but it's not a revelation
of a moment it's something as I pointed
out that requires habituation this is
what education does for this escaped or
liberated prisoner he's been given an
education in how things really do stand
how is this an allegory then we have to
think about the meaning for Plato's own
philosophy and what this might have to
say to us in a broader sense about
education in general so in Plato's view
what's most real is
not the visible things of the world the
material things that we encounter those
are just copies of the in material
intelligible that is understandable
forms or ideas the ideas or a day of
things in Greek and these are what allow
us to identify a dog is a dog or a man
is a man or a chair as a chair according
to Plato and we don't have to go very
deep into his doctrine of forms at this
point I can assume a certain
understanding or familiarity by with
this this idea for most people but
here's what's really important education
for Plato consists in coming out of a
cave where we are obsessed and
captivated by material objects we're
studying them we're making predictions
about them we're naming them but none of
them are truly what they are they're
merely shadows of the real things and
the real things are merely shadows of
the forms which we can encounter through
contemplation and through dialectic
through exercising our mental faculties
and that's what a genuine education
ought to be doing it should be leading
us away from the individual material
items and towards the genuine real forms
that are the archetypes of those items
this is what Plato thinks and we should
be doing this for example with the
notion of justice or the notion of
courage or any of these other virtues we
should also do this with numbers there's
all the entire discussion about how this
happens we're not quite at the end of
the story yet though because we should
arrive eventually at the equivalent of
the Sun in the allegory of the cave and
this is not simply one form among others
this is the most important the most
central form he calls it the form of the
good it is goodness itself
it is whatever goodness is and all
things that are good participate in that
primal goodness so this too is what
education ought to be doing not simply
introducing us to and this would be
enough already a myriad of distinct
different forms that are the archetypes
of the things that that we think exists
but the one that provides them with a
certain unity and order and beginning
the one that is the cause for all of
them the generative cause that that in
some way that Plato doesn't explain here
gives rise gives being to all of those
so this is what the allegory of the cave
is about it's not really as some people
like to say about you know the
transformative power of Education by
learning a few new facts it's not simply
about you know being introduced to some
new ideas and then getting yourself out
of the cave you can certainly make that
use of it but Plato's original import
Plato's original scope for this has a
metaphysical dimension you're supposed
to get to know what reality itself
is so that there is no further cave
outside of you know that that you would
be having to go out of after that point
this would be the bedrock this would be
the foundation and then it prepares you
for being able to go back into the cave
to liberate that is to educate your
fellow prisoners and that is another
part of the story
you